Atomenergie für Japan
nach dem Schrecken von Fukushima war ein
weiter so für viele undenkbar
der Super-GAU war schließlich sogar für
die damalige deutsche Kanzlerin 2011 der
Anlass aus der Atomkraft auszusteigen
[Musik]
doch der Katastrophe zum Trotz
japans Regierung setzt weiter auf
Kernenergie
mehr denn je
in Tom Joker verdeckt ein Blütenmeer
jede Erinnerung an das Grauen diese 420
Kirschbäume haben den Super-GAU von
Fukushima überlebt
Japans regierungschefische da schmückt
sich gerne mit der kirschblütenpracht
hält dort eine Gedenkrede zum Jahrestag
des Atomunfalls und vertraut doch weiter
auf die Kernenergie
für viele in der Provinz Fukushima
klingen seine Worte so als habe Japan
nichts aus der Katastrophe vor zwölf
Jahren gelernt
wir mussten damals ganze acht mal
umziehen einmal haben wir sogar in einer
Turnhalle gewohnt am Ende sind wir dann
in Fukushima City gelandet
die Regierung erklärt einfach zu wenig
sie entscheidet einfach und erklärt es
danach
11 märz 2011 Tom Joker zählt zu den
Orten die von Erdbeben Tsunami und
Atomunfall besonders hart getroffen
werden
durch das Beben kollabieren die
Kühlsysteme in beiden Kernkraftwerken
von Fukushima
es kommt zur Kernschmelze
große Mengen an Radioaktivität werden
freigesetzt mehr als 18.500 Menschen
sterben durch Erdbeben und Tsunami fast
eine halbe Million muss ihre Häuser
verlassen wegen der hohen
Strahlenbelastung
der Super-GAU verseucht das Land und
seine Bewohner
wir treffen
auch er musste damals aus seiner Heimat
fliehen ist aber zurückgekehrt in diesem
Jahr zeigt er seinen Enkeln zum ersten
Mal voller Stolz seine Geliebte
kirschbaumallee vor der Katastrophe
kamen Menschen aus ganz Japan hierher um
die Kirschblüte zu bestaunen heute sind
es nur wenige die Ernst völlig
verstrahlten Häuser neben der Allee
dürfen erst seit diesem april wieder
bewohnt werden
es könnte einen so wunderschöner ruhiger
Ort sein zum Wohnen aber bis heute ist
kaum jemand wiedergekommen nur alte
Frauen und Männer wie ich wollten zurück
aber die jungen Leute bleiben weg
54 Kernreaktoren waren in Japan vor der
Katastrophe von Fukushima am Netz
nach dem Atomunfall das ganze Land unter
Schock
landesweite Proteste
alle Reaktoren wurden abgestellt
anders als Deutschland steigt Japan aber
nicht aus der Kernenergie aus einige
Atom Meiler wurden bald wieder
hochgefahren vor kurzem hob die
Regierung die Laufzeitbegrenzung für
Kernkraftwerke auf 20% der Energie soll
bald wieder aus Atom Malern kommen Japan
setzt in Zeiten von Energieknappheit
wieder auf die Technologie die viele
Japaner mit einer Jahrhundertkatastrophe
verbinden
sie sind die stillen zeugen davon
zwischen den Kirschblüten und dem
Kernkraftwerk in Fukushima eine
gespenstische Kulisse
in Tom Joker scheint die Zeit stehen
geblieben zu sein seit 12 Jahren alles
verlassen und verfallen
wir finden unzählige Gebäude die sich
immer noch in genau dem Zustand befinden
indem sie von ihren Bewohnern verlassen
wurden
eine Geisterstadt
hier ist noch jede Menge Kleidung
Kinderspielzeug bei der nuklearen
Katastrophe wurde jede Menge
Radioaktivität freigesetzt zwei Elemente
Strontium und Cäsium allein Cäsium hat
eine Halbwertszeit von 30 Jahren also
viele dieser Häuser werden noch lange
Zeit unbewohnbar sein
zumindest bis sie vollständig die
kontaminiert wurden dieses Haus wird
gerade enttäuscht erklären uns die
Handwerker vor der Kamera wollen Sie
nicht mit uns sprechen das Thema ist
sensibel
bis heute kämpft die gesamte Region mit
den Folgen der Atomkatastrophe bis heute
gibt es hier No-Go areas dort ist die
Strahlenbelastung für Menschen immer
noch eine große Gefahr betreten verboten
auf unserer Fahrt fallen uns mehrere
Messstationen auf 0,6 Mikro sie wird die
Strahlenbelastung ist dreimal so hoch
wie der normale Durchschnitt
kaum ein Gewerbe kämpft bis heute wohl
so sehr mit den Folgen des Super-GAU wie
die Fischer in den vergangenen Jahren
hat sich ihr Arbeitsplatz
unwiederbringlich verändert sagen sie
sie geben der nuklear Katastrophe die
Schuld daran
die Wassertemperatur ist zwischen einem
und zwei Grad angestiegen das hat alles
verändert
wir fangen jetzt Fische die wir noch nie
gefangen haben
aber wir bekommen auch etliche
Fischarten gar nicht mehr
kleine Fische wie der sandal unsere
wichtigste Fischart und die beliebteste
hier bei den Leuten ist nicht mehr
vorhanden das ist ein furchtbarer Schlag
für uns
nach dem Atomunfall dürften die Fischer
zwei Jahre lang überhaupt nichts
verkaufen 54 Länder verhängten
einfuhrverbote für Fisch aus der Region
acht Länder halten bis heute daran fest
Fischer kämpfen bis heute damit den
schlechten Ruf ihrer wahre loszuwerden
damit nicht genug ihr Albtraum geht
weiter viele befürchten dass das Wasser
in dem die verbliebenen Fische leben
bald wieder verseucht wird
die Betreiberfirma der AKW in Fukushima
tepo will das verstrahlte Wasser ins
Meer leiten dazu wird in der Nähe von
Reaktor 5 ein Tunnel gebaut unter dem
Meeresgrund soll dann eine ein Kilometer
lange Röhre das behandelte Kühlwasser
ins Meer ableiten 850 Meter dieses
Tunnels sind bereits fertiggestellt
Tepco selbst hat sich dieses Projekt
beim havarierten Atommeiler von der
japanischen Regierung absegnen lassen
sechs Jahre lang haben Experten
unterschiedliche
Entsorgungsmöglichkeiten für das
radioaktive Kühlwasser diskutiert einen
Aufbereitungsverfahren namens Alps wurde
zur besten Lösung erklärt dabei werden
die radioaktiven Elemente Strontium und
Cäsium entfernt ein drittes Element
Tritium bleibt aber weiter im Wasser
enthalten
wir fragen Tepco warum ist der Konzern
für Sicherheit die radioaktiven
Rückstände ins Meer zu leiten
das Ergebnis war dass die Belastung bei
Menschen zwischen einem Millionstel und
einem 700.000 der natürlich vorkommenden
Strahlenbelastung liegt bei Tieren und
Pflanzen liegt die Belastung zwischen 3
Millionstel und eine Millionstel
verglichen mit dem empfohlenen Grenzwert
der internationalen Kommission für
Strahlenschutz die Auswirkungen sind
also eher gering
diese Untersuchungsergebnisse werden von
der internationalen
atomenergieaufsichtsbehörde anerkannt
auch den Fischern bleibt nichts anderes
übrig aber Sorgen machen sie sich
trotzdem nicht nur weil tepo in der
Vergangenheit mehrere wichtige
Informationen unter Verschluss gehalten
hat Tom mit zur Kondom befürchtet einen
erneuten Imageschaden für seine Zunft
und er ist doch wütend auf die
japanische Regierung
was mich richtig sauer macht ist dass
die Regierung die Abmachung die wir mit
ihr vor ein paar Jahren getroffen haben
mit Füßen tritt unsere Vereinbarung war
das ohne die Zustimmung von allen
Betroffenen das behandelte Kühlwasser
niemals ins Meer gelassen wird das war
ihr Versprechen und sie haben es
gebrochen das ist einfach unglaublich
die Regierung so empfinden es die Fische
will den Super-GAU von 2011 immer weiter
ausblenden aus den Augen aus dem Sinn
auf unserer Reise fällt uns auf dass die
schwarzen Plastiksäcke mit den Tonnen
kontaminierter Erde immer weiter aus dem
Sichtfeld verschwinden vor wenigen
Jahren stapelten sie sich noch Meter
hoch auf den Feldern jetzt wurden die
meisten inzwischen Lage abtransportiert
doch die Mehrheit der Landwirte bestellt
ihre Felder heute trotzdem nicht mehr
statt einem mehr schwarzer Säcke heute
andere schwarze Objekte
vor der Katastrophe wurden auf den
Äckern Reis und andere Feldfrüchte
angebaut aber Gemüse das den Ruf hat
verstrahlt zu sein verkauft sich
schlecht heute stehen hier Solarpaneele
die Region für kushima erfindet sich neu
als grün und erneuerbar
wird die Regierung heute mit dem Slogan
100% Strom aus Erneuerbaren bis 2014
hier bleiben alle Kernreaktoren weiter
abgeschaltet das gilt aber nur für
diesen einen Bezirk im restlichen Japan
plant die Regierung sogar neue
Atomkraftwerke zu bauen die liberale
Regierung hält sie für sicher und für
umweltfreundlich
die Dreifach-Katastrophe von Erdbeben
Tsunami und Supergau im Kernkraftwerk
sie hat Fukushima geläutet
doch das restliche Japan setzt weiter
voll auf Atomenergie
[Musik]